se baigner nu c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très agréable années soixante
dix axes devient le lieu phare des
vacances des naturistes sur une partie
du cap des constructions flambant neuve
accueille les touristes venus de
l'europe entière jusqu'à 35 mille chaque
kit de joël pour la blonde et moi j'ai
même pensé ça paraît léger la vie à poil
mais c'est avant tout une philosophie
quand on côtoie le naturiste ici c'est
un peu la sensation et puis le désir
quand tous ces gens là de vouloir se
libérer complètement et je crois que le
simple fait d'enlever un ce qu'ils
devaient suffire à faire libérer
beaucoup de chance et beaucoup de choses
chez les gens dans l'usinage les
naturistes bronze est connue se baigner
à poil suivi des salaires dans leur
course juste en claquettes personnes se
regardent via une discrétion qui
s'établit instantanément il ya le
respect de l'individu les textiles ceux
qui portent des vêtements sont les
bienvenus au village naturiste et
heureusement car les commerçants ne sont
que très peu havre abandonner leurs
tenues en état ne savais pas si c'était
moi qui était normal ou c'était c'est
qu'il est mort voir si vous pensez de ce
genre de la question n'est pas celle
qu'ils étaient
aguerri pas là et maintenant vous avez
pris l'habitude sommes citoyens pichon
sayah biais on va pas j'ai fait mon
patron voilà c'est beau la vie au cap
d'agde bronzage intégral impeccable
cohabitation parfaite avec le textile
mais trop beau pour durer dans les
années 90 un fléau fram les plages c'est
le voyeurisme une auto revenant
journellement sur des gens qui film qui
met cachent les caméras dans un sac et
qui se promènent sur la plage ou dans le
quartier et qui filme partie les parties
génitales des hommes ou femmes pour
faire n'importe quoi sans compter que le
cap d'agde acquis une réputation
sulfureuse échangisme libertinage des
pratiques pas très bien vu des
vacanciers naturiste les touristes de la
première heure regrette un temps où la
nudité n'était au cap d'agde aucun moyen
de se sentir libre en accord avec la
nature
[Musique]